today the stock market rebounded after
dropping over 2,000 points during the
previous two trading sessions now that
kind of volatility is making a lot of
people nervous and II just curious if
you have any thoughts about the current
state of the stock market
well nothing original or insightful but
you know I can spout empty meaningless
investing cliches empty meaningless
investing cliches Andy are you proposing
that we have a good old fashioned stock
market cliche battle that's exactly what
I'm proposing all right all right here
we go
the topic is the US stock market Andy
what are your thoughts
look investors have to remember that
what goes up must come down
exactly Andy now and then you need a
bear to slow down the bull and at times
like these patients have hurt you you've
got to be in it to win it and as long as
you didn't put all your eggs in one
basket you should be able to ride out
the storm
I agree Andy I agree you know everyone
looks like a genius in a bull market but
when the tide goes out you can see who's
swimming naked I say instead of crying
everyone should be buying now there are
people who say you should never try to
catch a falling knife but remember it's
a marathon not a sprint so don't throw
the baby out with the bathwater my
advice stay in the market because you
miss 100% of the shots you don't take
yeah truer words were never spoken
but you also gotta know when to hold
them and know when to fold them no one
to walk away no one to run you never
count your money when you're sitting at
the table
there'll be time enough for countin when
the dealin's done ok I gotta say any now
you're Kenny Rogers lyrics make a good
point but don't forget no money mo
problems
and cash rules everything around me get
the money dollar dollar bill y'all got
my mind on my money and my money I'm a
mind well I like big butts and I cannot
lie
Wow idiom I'm sorry that's that's not an
investing cliche Oh Conan you can be
such a dick okay let that get a ding
that's not a cliche around here it is
you guys turned on me fast they just
love winners they do
you